from the film's website the About
section it says that you went in 2008
personally to walk the Camino at that
point did you know where you were
planning to make a film where were you
at in your life well I absolutely had no
intentions of making this film when I
walked it was really I was I was in
between jobs relationships and homes and
in me let's say it was the fall of 2007
and to be honest you know I had a couple
months I felt sorry for myself not
having those things and then one day it
just occurred to me it's sort of out of
the blue like I should take advantage of
not having these things you know all my
stuff was in storage and I was in
between jobs and and so I it just dawned
on me that I should do the Camino it
kind of was just like a divine
inspiration I guess you could say I had
lived in Spain for about six years so I
had always sort of known about the
Camino but it never occurred to me to do
it until that moment and so then within
a couple of months I was on the Camino
and walking and I was just walking for
me I had been engaged to be married and
that wasn't the right fit and so my life
was just a little bit I wasn't sure
where I was going and so I ended up on
the Camino and when people found out one
man in particular when he found out I
was a filmmaker he said oh you should do
a documentary on the Camino and my
answer was absolutely not under no
circumstances I had independently
produced and directed a short
documentary about 15 years before and
swore I would never ever do it again
it was just so challenging to raise all
the money and do everything without the
support of a production company or a TV
station but my other big hesitation was
for me the Camino is so sacred and so
magical I was really scared I couldn't
do it justice and so I was really
hesitant and it wasn't until I got home
and probably a good three four weeks
after that I decided to do the film it
was really like that little voice that
kept saying
you need to do this you really need to
make a documentary on it and so finally
I kind of succumbed and six years later
here we are
one of the subjects in your film Tomas I
mean he says that the Camino changes
most people who walk it did it change
you and how it definitely changed me I
there's a saying on the Camino that your
real Camino starts when you get home and
and I think that was definitely the case
for me for me walking the Camino was
it's not that it was easy but compared
to making a film or distributing the
film it was way easier than those things
and the making of the film was very
analogous to the walking I really needed
to reach out and ask for a lot of help
and I had so many people literally
thousands of people that helped me make
this film and that's very much like on
the Camino most people really get a lot
of help they have these wonderful kind
Oh spittle arrows usually they're
wonderful and kind that is and who
helped you along the way and sometimes
they'll care for your blisters take an
hour out of their day just to tend to
your feet and expecting nothing in
return so I had a lot of that on my
journey and making the film as well and
I think in terms of how I changed I
think my big lesson from the Camino was
really learning how much I was capable
of I think before I wasn't really living
up to my potential I kind of was very
content with staying behind the scenes
and being a producer and not necessarily
supporting or believing in my own vision
and this was really a case of me think
saying this is something I believe in
this is important and I'm gonna go after
it so we've heard from many in the film
we also saw that it's physically
difficult at points to walk the Camino
emotionally how is it difficult mmm I
think it's different for each person and
that's what makes the Camino I think so
magical is it's not this one blanket
experience and what may be difficult for
one person is easy for another and I'm
going back on a physical level for me
for example the physical walking wasn't
that challenging but the staying the
snoring was a really challenging part
for me and emotionally I had a really
interesting experience when I walked my
brother passed when I was 10 and I'd
done lots of workshops and work around
my brother's death and then when I was
walking the Camino it was almost like he
had died the year before and it and also
on kind of the positive end I really
felt him I mean it was like he was there
with me
and so I think I kind of went through a
lot more grief and I felt for me at
least on the come you know the goods
were so great and the pain was so deep
like it was everything is sort of
magnified and amplified and so it ends
up being emotionally difficult I think
for each person in their own way some
people have huge problems with the
Meseta which is this flat long section
where there's nothing to look at and
it's just fields and I personally really
love that section so it's it's just so
unique for everybody so then again you
said that the real magic of the Camino
the real changing of it happens when you
come home and why do you think that is
and how was it for you well I think I
think it's it's different for everybody
that but I think the Camino sort of
seeps into your life and continues to
affect you over time and for me it was
really this calling to do to make this
film and it's been extremely challenging
and simultaneously I really feel like
there's a part of me that feels like the
reason I'm on this planet and the reason
I was born was to make this film like
the
was part of my destiny or I'm not even
sure what the words are but I know I'm
doing what I'm supposed to be doing like
this is what I'm supposed to be doing
and that's a very fulfilling thing to be
you know feeling like okay I'm doing
what I'm here to do you think more the
Martin Sheen connection that's kind of a
long story
because Emilio and Martin were over in
Spain doing some pre-production and
raising some money at the very same time
I was they were like in Santiago
literally days before I was so I
contacted them let them know I was
making this documentary and we were both
gonna film around the same time and as
it turns out they had to delay their
shooting until the fall of 2009 and I
was shooting spring 2009 so we shot and
we immediately put together this 23
minute trailer which was to raise money
and show potential funders and I sent it
to Martin and he loved it and he showed
it to me Leo and Martin later told me
that Emilio showed it to some of his
cast and crew members to really give
them an idea of what it's like to be on
the Camino and so that was very sweet
and then we kind of stayed in touch
and obviously Emilio came out the way
came out way earlier than them we did
and there was a point in time when they
were missing some shots and they were
gonna license some footage but then they
ended up going back and reshooting and
so so we're in touch and talking now and
then and what happened was they did a
kind of a pre-screening at the at
Georgetown University it was this huge
screening it was like 500 it was sort of
a gala event and there was you know the
Spanish ambassador and all these people
even some of the Spanish royalty came to
it and so during the Q&A after the
screening I was there because I was part
of a pilgrimage conference and this the
screening was part of this pilgrimage
conference that I was presenting at
and so during this emmaus big screening
people were doing Q&A so I stood up and
said hi it's Lydia from the Camino
documentary because they both knew what
I sounded like but they they knew who I
was but they didn't know what I look
like and Martin just went off and he
just was so kind in he just immediately
was saying that Lydia's made this great
documentary and she's run out of money
so if anybody has a bag of money they
really should give it to her it's a
brilliant documentary and it's real
people and to me that was really one of
the most kind gestures someone could do
in the screening of their own film to go
on and on and try and help somebody else
so that's why I helped I mean I thanked
Martin and Emilia has been quite kind to
I we were negotiations with a
distributor that they used and so he
kind of has been letting me know how
that worked out for them and
recommending them and so they've been
and I'm extremely grateful to the way
because because of that film there's so
many more people that are interested in
the Camino and want to know more and
then they come to our film so we were
very blessed to have them come out a
couple years before us Lydia we
understand from a tweet that your film
has made over half a million dollars
screening thus far we keep hearing that
theatrical was dead so how did this
happen well we did something very unique
with our theatrical distribution we did
it on our own and we have we have
grossed over
we're almost at 600,000 but excuse me
that's gross that's not our take what
essentially we've done is we've done one
screening at a time and what we would do
is our first really big screening well
our first first theatrical screening was
in Ashland Oregon and we had been in the
film festival there and we sold out all
our screenings so we said okay this is a
great market to go back clearly people
want to see this film
and we were just so amazed with no
advertising really to speak of we stayed
they extended us for six weeks and what
we do is we usually I usually try and
show up for opening weekend I come armed
with two five hundred fliers and ask
everybody to help us spread the word
take ten flyers and pass them out and so
our our method has really been
word-of-mouth and we really ask people
to help us and and then we also do
outreach we do before a film is before
the film is going to be showing in a
city we'll reach out to outdoor stores
churches any walking groups yoga studios
and we try and do a lot of grassroots
outreach and what we did is each
screening essentially funds the next one
and then the other really unique thing
that we did is I financed an RV had it
wrapped with our our logo and then I did
a whole cross-country tour I literally
went all the way around the country
there was one section two-week section
that Annie took on for me thank God
because I was getting pretty tired at
that point but pretty much we went all
the way across around the country and
I'm thinking we're guessing that I've
probably appeared somewhere at like a
hundred different events a hundred
different cities and done over 200 q and
A's something something that number so
it's really been about appearing and and
trying to enlist local people to help us
spread the word and I also think there's
a real desire in our country right now
I'm hurt somebody refer to it as
spiritual dehydration there are real
longing for more meaning in our lives
and to go to a movie that's uplifting
and inspiring rather than depressing and
disturbing so I think I think people are
ready for that do you think that's since
the recession because so many people's
lives have been really uprooted they
had to make changes you know that
probably does have a pretty big effect
and I think too it's easy to get
distracted when you're you're making
money and you're getting the new toys
and you can go shopping and this and
that and then all of a sudden that's not
an option anymore you can't distract
yourself with more buying more things
and but I think it's also just the
natural evolution of our society I think
little by little where people are
seeking more meaning and more connection
with each other with our communities and
with the spiritual aspect of ourselves
there's something I'd like to adjust so
for me it was really important to show
it in theaters because my intention in
making the film was to bring the Camino
to people so that they could have a
Camino experience just sitting in their
chair
it wasn't about trying to inspire
everybody to go do the Camino but it was
having everybody at least get a glimmer
or a sliver of the lessons and of the
magic of the Camino which would inspire
them to do whatever they're meant to do
be it vehicle walk the Camino or open a
homeless shelter or spend more time with
their grandchildren and for me seeing it
in theaters was particularly important
because it sort of mimics the Camino
experience you're having this semi
intimate experience with a bunch of
strangers and so and also being on the
big screen you get much more of a sense
of being there of being on the Camino do
you think theatrical distribution is
dead that being said I know you you
wanted that and I agree that I think
that that would lend itself especially
for your film oh I absolutely do not
think theatrical is is dead I think
people really longed for that night out
going out and sharing an experience
maybe it's just a subconscious desire to
share an experience with people but I
really think there's something very
special about being in that dark room no
interruptions you know the baby's not
crying the dogs not throwing up the
phone's not ringing I mean you're really
there to
step into that experience and I think no
matter how big our TVs get you're not
going to have that same experience at
home having found so much success with
the theatrical distribution what do you
think it is that's lent itself to that
aside from having an amazing film it's
very emotional I connected very much
with all of your subjects in the film
but do you think it's a snowball effect
from other people talking about it or
their own personal experiences on the
Camino
I think we were very blessed it was sort
of a perfect storm in a positive way
because we had a film that people with
this film people can say so often when
you when you walk the Camino you come
home and people are like how was it and
it's like you can't even begin to talk
about it you can't how do you even start
to explain it and this was one of the
reasons I made the film as well was this
way people could say watch this that's
what I went through now obviously I
can't touch on every experience or every
person's but there's some general themes
that everybody that walks goes through
and I to capture as many of those as
possible and so we had that element so
very frequently people come to see our
film once like somebody that's walked
they'll come and see it once and then
the next night they'll bring three
friends and then two nights later
they'll bring you know their brother and
their sister-in-law and two other people
because they want to be able to share
their Camino experience with people and
there's just been this huge increase of
interest and of people walking the
Camino and so there's a wonderful
organization called American pilgrims
here in the US and they have separate
pilgrim chapters all over the country so
we worked very closely with those
chapters and so they would get all their
friends and they would usually use it as
an event to help people that are
thinking about doing the Camino okay
these are some of the things that you
might encounter if you do the Camino and
so we haven't we had that going for us
we had the fact
that the way had come out previously so
there was literally thousands of people
that had gone and walked the Camino from
when they saw the way to when our film
came out and additionally I think that
spiritual dehydration I think people are
a lot of people are really excited about
seeing a film where nothing blows up and
nobody gets murdered I mean you know I'm
the first one I you know I I love my TV
shows and you know kind of escapist
movies but to a point you know I really
do enjoy something that makes me feel
good
was there a group of filmmakers that you
modeled this way of screening the film
after or was there a book where you felt
okay if we don't get a distribution deal
we're gonna do it ourselves we're gonna
do it this way not really there was in
some ways I mean I I was really inspired
by what the bleep because they didn't
get into a bunch of they didn't go the
normal route they didn't get into film
festivals they didn't get into or lots
of them they got into some and they
didn't have a big production company
behind them they didn't have a big
distributor now they did have a much
much bigger budget than we did but they
still had a very self distribution model
but there wasn't a ton of information
about it but as I guess it was when we
were at the Hollywood Film Festival
where we won Best Documentary our DVD
distributor introduced me to Betsey
chassis one of the creators of what the
bleep and she's just been lovely she's
been like a mentor to me and really
encouraging but I can't say there was an
exact model I mean I did read a lot of
books and I got little pieces from lots
of different things and I also it a lot
of the making of this film and the
distribution of this film has really
been happened on an intuitive level I
just kind of get this sense or I'm like
this would be a good thing to do and
I've learned to trust that and that's
been a big part of my Camino and what
I've learned is really to trust my
intuition and so the big part of it was
I should get an RV and if I'm
to me so many filmmakers are like oh I
just want to make the film but to me
it's kind of like birthing a baby and
then giving it up for adoption I mean
it's a choice to do but to really make
sure that the film gets out in the world
and the way you want it to like for
example I mean for me theatrical was
important because I really feel like
people can have the whole experience and
I and I also can't imagine that that
many distributors would have done with
it the way the way I I did it and it was
a very personal touch obviously and also
to the the you're going there in 2008
was very similar to all the reasons the
other people went and I think reasons
why others would go as well so I think
that's important for you to share your
own yeah yeah and I think I think that
is a really key thing that makes the
film a little bit different there's been
a some movies that are gonna be coming
out shortly or have come out in the past
of filmmakers doing films about their
Camino as they walk it one of the issues
about that though I feel like I had the
great benefit of walking having a
complete pilgrim experience then going
back because if you're walking and
shooting you can't really have the
normal pilgrim experience because you're
working and so much about the pilgrim
experiences you know not being
distracted and not having a million
things to do that really your to-do list
is walk eat sleep and you know if you
want wash your clothes I mean so it's I
think it's a much harder experience to
try and walk and capture it and at the
same time rather than doing one first
than the other what's the most common
question you're asked at the q and A's
the most common question here I go I'm
repeating the question I'd say the most
common question I get is how did I pick
my characters and the short answer to
that is
for me it was really important to let
the Camino cast the movie actually and
it was not about me arriving with a
bunch of people and saying this is who's
meant to be in the film that it was
really about who was presented to me
because that's another thing that
happens when you walk you meet people
they kind of become presented to you
like for example when I walked the very
first day I walked with had the same
name as my ex-fiance and kind of some
very similar issues came about with this
guy that I just met that was the very
same with my ex-fiance and that happens
frequently on the Camino so I really
wanted to let the Camino cast the movie
but that said obviously I needed
somebody to shoot the first day and I
also knew I needed somebody that had the
courage to be a hundred percent
vulnerable and essentially show what was
going on on the inside and what happened
with that was I was friends with a knio
knio from many years ago and when she I
was talking to her and I was telling her
about this project and she was just
immediately called and said I want to be
involved I want to walk it and I
realized how great she would be she's
funny she's open and she's very
courageous and so she was our first
pilgrim and then everybody else we just
kind of picked up along the way and that
said I was also very clear about wanting
to have a variety of Ages nationalities
reasons for doing the Camino spiritual
religious or none so that was really
important I wanted to try and have it
reflect what you would see if you were
on the Camino speaking of intuition that
was actually my next question so it's
working very well because you had said
somewhere else that you wanted to stay
out of the way of your own film and let
the em you know dictate sort of how it
was going to be how do you think we as
filmmakers get in the way of our work I
found that fascinating we said that I
think when we come up with a plan and
stick to it no matter how much the
university is kind of going no you
should go this way
I think when you get dead set like it
has to be this way rather than just kind
of going with the flow and I for me it
was really about just setting that
intention of I want this to be the
Caminos film I want this to be the
highest and greatest thing that it can
be and I want it to be if the Camino was
a person and could make the film that's
what I want and so I might have my my
things I mean personally if if it was
just me and my film we would have had
like six sections on snoring but you
know thank God for editors but I also
realized that like no that's that's that
was just my issue it's not everybody's
issue I think that's the biggest thing
is is setting an intention more than
anything and not necessarily worrying
about how it has to fulfill itself but
just saying this is my intention and I'm
gonna trust that it's gonna come out
that way and I also did what's called
visioning it's a process one of my
spiritual teachers is Reverend Michael
Beckwith and I was trained as a
practitioner at agape and he has this
thing called visioning which is sort of
going into a meditative state and sort
of letting things come to you so the
idea being and I feel like this that
it's it's really kind of coming through
me not rather just rather than
originated originating with me it's
coming kind of through rather than just
starting here and coming out any advice
to fellow filmmakers on when they find
themselves getting in their way or being
too attached to the results of something
but they're feeling were there other
instances aside from the story which I
thought was very funny that the few that
you did have in there was right but um
where you found you know what I need to
get out of the way of this film I'm
coming in too much I'm a big proponent
of meditation
I think quieting our minds
and just calming the mind and for me
it's it's totally a practice I would not
say I am totally successful at quieting
my mind by no means but it is the
practice of doing that and of sitting
every day so that that is what really
works for me and on the shoot many times
I I had two people on the on the crew
that were very solid meditators they
also had a daily practice and
occasionally when I just felt really
just completely at odds with everything
I would grab one of them and say come
meditate with me and even just 10
minutes made a really big difference and
Annie also was a really big support for
me on the shoot she because she's from
agape we did what's called spiritual
mind treatment and she would really kind
of try and hold me in in consciousness
there's there's a bunch of terminology
that we use but she was really very
helpful as well
and let me think I think the other thing
that that from my spiritual work that
I've really learned to lean into is that
what looks like an obstacle or what
looks like really horrible news can be
great news and that was one of those
things that you know each time something
came up like I had this really big
insight about I was so frustrated at how
long it was taking me to raise the money
to finish the film and it was so hard
and I you know the way shot after us and
they came out years before and I was so
frustrated
you know just struggling with trying to
get the money and it was we were in
Portland for 11 weeks for our first run
and it was after coming back from one of
those q a's I was on there I was walking
down to my house and it just dawned on
me what was so challenging in that
moment has been my biggest blessing
because because the way came out two
years before it paved the way for us and
it made our way so much easier
and so there was really a blessing in it
and the more you can lean into that and
go okay I'm really unhappy with this
situation and I'm sure there's something
good coming from this and just keep
yourself in that and and be open to the
what good that could what good be could
be happening that you're not aware of
just yet and even to your life in 2007
is probably difficult as it was yes it
shook things up but then you went on the
camino and look what's happened as a
result exactly same type of thing and
that seemed to be a theme yeah and the
other thing I wanted to mention that as
I personally do a lot of work on myself
and I think that's very important I work
with a spiritual practitioner on a very
consistent basis and that was a big part
of the film because my stuff was getting
was coming up a lot of people in the
crew a lot of people kind of connected
to the film their stuff is coming up and
without having someone that I was
consistently working with to go this is
coming up you know what how am i
contributing to this and how do I need
to shift and where where can I grow and
how can I be more of who I really want
to be and and I also work with a
therapist on you know he he's kind of I
call him now and then when things come
up I'm just a really big proponent of
getting help of you know I don't think
we're here on this planet meant to try
and figure everything out by ourselves I
really think that give and take and
having somebody outside yourself and
especially when it's somebody
professional because it's a lot of
pressure I think to put on our friends
like I'm going through this really hard
time helped me and not only that they're
not trained and but the more we can kind
of look at ourselves and look at what's
happening on my side of the street like
you may be doing what what's going on
over here but I have the opportunity to
look at it differently to reframe it to
to
really step into Who I am instead of
getting sucked into just a reaction so
2007-2008 you walk the Camino you decide
then you want to make the film how did
you actually get it off the ground and
get the funds over this what five six
year period to make the movie well the
initial part as soon as I decided to
make the film I reached out to two
people two women I had worked with
extensively over the years documentary
filmmakers and Cobie Atlas and Keira
Thompson Keira just won a she as a
producer supervising producer on the
voice and Kobe was is amazing vice
president of PBS for programming used to
be and now she's doing a gazillion other
things so I reached out to them and they
helped me kind of get my footing and I
had raised I had actually raised enough
money I'd raise $60,000 for another
documentary and when I wanted to do this
one I just asked our donors if they
would be willing to let me transfer it
and then I reached out to my very first
boss Teresa - Lina Coleman and asked her
if I could run the film through her
nonprofit which is what I'd done with my
short documentary and as soon as she
heard about the the subject she was like
I want to be involved I want to work on
it and it just so happened that she had
the exact same amount of money that she
needed to invest into a film because
it's a non-profit so it needed to be
kind of recirculated and so we had just
enough for a super bare-bones shoot I
mean it was we were paying people $100 a
day
but luckily since I'd worked in the film
industry most of my life people were I
could get great people and they were
doing it as a favor to me and so we
actually did run out of money on the
shoot and I had to put in some of my own
life savings just a bit but some and
then afterwards we came back we cut
together this 23 minute fun
in trailer and you know I knew it
wouldn't be easy but I thought okay you
know we'll apply to some foundations and
some religious institutions and
government institutions and you know
Spanish tourism and all these places but
of course that was right when the crash
happened and Spain was just a mess I
mean there was just no money there
whatsoever and we got turned down right
left and center all the traditional
funding sources except for one grant we
got from Pacific pioneer fund and then
we did we also got two small grants from
American pilgrims but then everything
else was all raised from individuals and
I what happened was after about a year
and a half of trying the traditional
funding I realized I wasn't it wasn't
gonna happen that way and I it pretty
much turned into me asking everyone I'd
ever met or knew for money and here was
a case though I really had to kind of do
some work around my issues with money
and asking for money and asking for help
and what was really neat and really
extremely touching was my high school
classmates really turned out and it was
they funded almost 40% of the posts of
that phase of once I needed to finish
the film and incredibly supportive
people I hadn't seen in 30 years sending
in thousand-dollar checks and and then I
had four out of five of my funding
producers I had gone to high school with
and I was also really the one of my
classmates is Dan Brown who did the da
Vinci Code and he and his wife stepped
in and funded the whole online process
once they saw the rough cut and they
were just really touched and believed in
the project and if it wasn't for Dan and
Blythe I might still be fundraising
advice to other filmmakers on doing the
same not only just getting over the
hurdle of having to ask for help which
is a big thing we all you know DIY we
want to do this ourselves no we
anyone's help but ways to do it ways to
get over yeah um there's a couple of
books I really recommend I think kind of
working on your internal stuff with with
money is the first step I think pretty
much everything we do really is from
from the inside out there's a book
called spiritual economics by Eric
Butterworth the power the soul of money
by Lynne twist and then Lynne twist also
has a CD set fundraising from the heart
and I think that the the biggest thing I
would encourage people is only do things
that you're a hundred and ten percent
believe are gonna do some good in the
world there has to be something fueling
you more than money more than fame like
some really inherits strong pull for you
because it's just too hard otherwise I
mean to sustain it I think so was there
a moment where you felt burnout where
you felt like my back skins well I don't
know how I can continue and then how did
you pull yourself up there were many
many many many many moments it's been a
constant constantly falling down and
getting back up I mean each face has had
these huge you know I I thought for sure
I was going to get this grant and the
executive director from the Catholic
media campaign and and I thought for
sure it was gonna happen and it was like
no again and I I did have I had a little
ritual and I still do to a degree this
day when I'm going through a rough time
when I get a big disappointment I really
allow myself to feel it I a lot of times
it involves the fetal position and a lot
of tears and then it's like I go to a
movie I get popcorn and I cry and then I
get up the next day and start again and
it's pretty I wouldn't say it's constant
but it's it doesn't stop I mean as as
successful as the film has been we still
keep having so many challenges and
financially we're still we're just
getting by
just because everything is so expensive
but I think it's my I think the biggest
thing I would say is not denying the
pain or the frustration or the
disappointment and simultaneously not
wallowing in it letting yourself have
that and for me having a ritual around
it of like okay another rejection I'm
gonna go to my movie I'm gonna do this
and then I'm gonna start again